[Music]
my favorite part of my job is being able
to connect with these wild places and
these wild animals that we have in our
state
[Applause]
we work in an area with an extremely
healthy bear population
and so we located this pine tree along a
trail that the bears have been using as
a marking and scratching
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the first time you start to see the
bears on the back of the camera it's
really funny oh look at that face
[Music]
scratching
it's almost used as a social media to
them to where they can scratch their
backs and say hey i'm in this area and
i'm here to mate or whatever they want
to communicate to other bears in the
area
it's actually quite tricky to set the
cameras i'm a little bit psychologically
damaged
from this process
because almost every single time you
walk to that camera something's gone
wrong
either a bears knocked it over
a hurricane
knocks the camera into the swamp
so many times it doesn't work
but there have been some times when i
look at the camera and i know in that
moment like this is a picture that the
world's gonna see and fall in love with
these bears
and that gives me the strength and the
confidence to keep pushing
on our camera traps you're using a
passive infrared trigger you've got to
set your trigger sensitivity and you
don't want that trigger going off every
time the flock of turkeys walks by
but you also want it sensitive enough so
that if a
bear goes to scratch its back it starts
taking a picture
so
the best replica we have is
ourselves and we get our backs on that
tree and make sure all the cameras
trigger and test everything looks like
the
and it actually feels kind of good once
you get into it
an interesting thing about the bear
scratch trees the things you learn from
seeing those videos so it's one thing to
have a grainy trail cam picture but to
have a 4k
crisply focused image of a bear
scratching us back on a tree this you
can't see these things almost
every bear as it stands there scratching
its back is simultaneously
urinating on the ground i don't think
the scientists knew that
and so it's a window into this truly
wild world
and for me personally setting up
cameras and going to these places almost
every other week i've been able to
truly understand them
and connect with actual individual
animals that i see on the back of the
camera and that's why we're here and
we're fighting to protect these places
that's what it's all about
carlton and malia wildlife heroes from
the southern swamps
[Music]